[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 14 décembre voici le
programme et on commence par du sport ce
soir la France affrontera le Maroc pour
la demi-finale de Coupe du monde de
football un match teinté d'histoire
puisque le Maroc est le premier pays
africain à atteindre les demi la France
elle compte bien accéder en finale pour
peut-être obtenir une troisième étage
étoile à son maillot qu'on envoie à 20h
alors où regarder le match dans les
Yvelines quel est l'ambiance nous
suivrons sur le terrain notre
journaliste Grégory canalet accompagné
la transition écologique au sein de la
filière automobile voici l'objectif du
nouveau campus des métiers situés à
l'usine Renault Flins face aux enjeux de
décarbonation ce site souhaite notamment
développer les métiers du recyclage du
tri et du comme le fait de remplacer son
moteur thermique par un moteur
électrique ou à hydrogène nous ferons le
point avec notre journaliste Nicolas
dandry et la directrice du campus c'est
notre invité et comme chaque mercredi
nous parlerons de cinéma dans votre 7 8
cette semaine focus particulièrement sur
Avatar 2 la voix de l'eau c'est la suite
du plus gros succès du cinéma mondial
dans un univers marin spectaculaire nous
en parlerons avec le directeur du ciné 7
d'Élancourt et on retrouve tout de suite
sur le terrain Grégory canalet notre
journaliste Grégory vous êtes au bar up
to you situé à Montigny le Bretonneux
oui Mathilde parce que comme dans de
nombreux bars yvelinois la rencontre de
ce soir entre la France et le Maroc
c'est demi-finale de la Coupe du Monde
sera diffusée ici dans cet établissement
qui fait face au vélo de Drôme national
de 50 ans en Yvelines alors même si la
rencontre est à 20h les supporters
commencent à arriver l'ambiance monte
petit à petit ici avant ce match et je
suis avec Sonia kettou bonsoir vous êtes
la directrice de cet établissement
up to you à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
est-ce que beaucoup de monde est attendu
ce soir pour cette rencontre alors
énormément de monde justement c'est pour
ça qu'on a essayé d'optimiser au mieux
l'espace vous pouvez avoir pour
accueillir maximum de personnes ne
frustrer personne pourra soutenir la
France ce soir est-ce que vous savez si
on va avoir beaucoup de supporters de la
France quelques supporters du Maroc
aussi je pense qu'on va quand même
quelques supporters du Maroc et après
forcément les franco-marocains on en a
aussi quelques-uns ici donc le coeur va
balancer entre les deux équipes en tout
cas nous on est pour la France mais que
le meilleur gagne on sent que
l'engouement monte petit à petit autour
de cette équipe de France qui en plus
défend son titre de champion du monde
ici au Web to you est-ce que les
supporters étaient présents dès les
premiers matchs où ça ça monte petit à
petit depuis le deuxième tour et ce
huitième de finale face à la face à la
Pologne alors
ça notamment le match dernier ou là pour
le coup on a eu une influence
records de finale tout à fait donc
c'est venu gentiment jusqu'à arriver en
car et là l'écart on démarre assez sur
des chapeaux de roue quoi alors la
France est quand même favorite dans
cette rencontre est-ce que vous avez un
petit pronostic pour ce soir
moi personnellement j'irai de 1
Mathilde peut-être en plateau est-ce que
vous avez un pronostic pour la rencontre
de ce soir moi je dirais 1-0 pour la
France mais peut-être de 1 pour la
France c'est possible et Grégory j'ai
une question pour les Yvelines qui ne
souhaitent pas se rendre dans un bar ou
qui ne souhaite pas regarder le match
chez eux est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
solutions dans les Yvelines oui d'autres
solutions existent il y a des communes
notamment qui se mobilisent et qui vont
et diffuser également la rencontre de ce
soir sur écran géant alors quelques
exemples à vous proposer notamment à
Houdan le et donner à la salle des fêtes
du côté du Perray-en-Yvelines on est
mobilisé depuis le début de cette Coupe
du monde avec la diffusion de tous les
matchs de l'équipe de France sur écran
géant ça se passe à la salle des fêtes
de la Mareu loup qui a 250 places assis
si vous êtes alors plutôt supporter du
Maroc on disait qu'ici dans ce bar il y
aurait surtout des supporters de
l'équipe de France il y a une solution
qui s'offre à vous c'est le hall 5 du
parc des expositions de Mantes-la-Jolie
qui est un peu le camp de base des
supporters des Lions d'Atlas depuis le
début de la compétition vu nombre de
nombreuses scènes de liesse notamment
dans la ville de Mantes-la-Jolie et
enfin à Poissy le forum Armand Peugeot
ouvre de nouveaux ses portes poissons on
le rappelle qu'il est la ville d'origine
d'un joueur des Bleus qui est
sélectionné au Mondial il ne sera
vraisemblablement pas titulaire ce soir
c'est Mateo et genouzien qui est natif
de Poissy et je vous précise aussi que
pour toutes ces rencontres diffusées sur
écran géant l'entrée sera gratuite à
chaque fois donc de nombreuses solutions
existent les communes à yvinoises mais
il y a aussi des barres comme ici à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
et bien merci beaucoup Grégory canalet
on vous retrouvera tout à l'heure en fin
d'émission pour refaire le point avec
vous à quelques heures du match sur
l'ambiance dans le bar avec nous
également en plateau Robert Vallières
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes le
directeur général d'Evelyne fibre le
département des Yvelines est un
territoire plutôt bien fibré 98% des
foyers du réseau Yvelines fibre possède
sont équipés de la fibre et saine
Evelyne numérique avec qui vous
travaillez en étroite collaboration a
reçu une récompense c'est c'est
excusez-moi c'est c'est un prix qui qui
vous marque c'est un bel aboutissement
c'est à dire que c'est divine numérique
c'est le bras armé du département pour
l'aménagement numérique du territoire et
cette Évelyne numérique à travers un
appel d'offres mener également par le
Département a retenu TDF pour fibrer 150
communes les communes les plus rurales
du département et de faire ça dans un
temps qui était imparti donc
2021 et TDF s'est engagé avec Yvelines
Philippe sa filiale invisible s'est
engagé à réaliser ce déploiement
uniquement sur fond propre c'est-à-dire
que c'est un engagement sans
argent public oui parce que vous
travaillez sur ce déploiement depuis
2017 on a signé le contrat avec le
département et Saive du numérique fin
2017 et donc c'est un déploiement qui
s'est étalé sur entre 2018
2021-2022 pour raccorder plus de 100 000
foyers
plus en détail dans quelques instants
avec nous également Sylvie Artigues du
jeunesse bonsoir bonsoir vous en parlez
un instant vous êtes la directrice du
campus qui vient d'ouvrir
Flins-sur-Seine ce nouveau campus alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous le présenter
alors c'est un nouveau campus en effet
qui est dédié intégralement à l'économie
circulaire ce qui est un nouveau c'est
le premier campus qui permet de le faire
en étant intégralement dédié à la
préparation des métiers qui vont
accompagner la transition de la filière
automobile
intégrant les objectifs les grands
objectifs presque de la planète et de la
décarbonation et Nicolas dandry vous y
était également à ce lancement de ce
nouveau campus ce matin alors et vous
avez pu suivre cette visite qu'est-ce
que vous avez pu voir
effectivement j'étais à cette visite et
on voit que finalement cette transition
de l'usine de Flins débuter dès
l'annonce en 2020 avec la renolution
annoncée par Lucas DeMeo Dominique
Sénart les deux grands dirigeants du
groupe Renault et bien on voit la
concrétisation disons de la
transformation de l'usine de Flins de la
production puisque historiquement
l'usine de Flins produit des véhicules
Renault vers ce dont on parlait notre
invité vers un site dédié à l'économie
circulaire et on en reparlera dans cette
chronique qui suit on fera le point avec
vous dans un instant Michael el midoro
bonsoir journaliste de la rédaction vous
allez nous présenter les informations
d'aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines
exactement on va parler dans quelques
instants de la neige qui est tombé alors
les quelques millimètres de neige
centimètres par endroits sont tombés
dans les Yvelines on en parlera dans
quelques instants et on parlera
également du dispositif pour le match de
ce soir 250 policiers seront mobilisés
sur les festivités qui sont sûrement
organisés juste après le match et ce
sera juste après mais avant jetons un
petit coup d'œil à la météo de demain
demain matin le ciel le sera voilé sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera encore très froid
compter moins 4 degrés à Rambouillet - 3
ou dans et Versailles et moins de degrés
à Mantes-la-Jolie mais les ressentis
seront en moyenne de moins 8 degrés
alors couvrez-vous bien dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se dégager
avec quelques éclaircies au niveau des
températures il fera 1 degré à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan et
zéro à Rambouillet et demain nous
fêterons la sainte Ninon le pont
maintenant sur l'actualité dans les
Yvelines
et c'est avec vous mais qu'elle est
midro on commence par ces images de
neige qui ont recouvert les Yvelines on
sait tous se réveiller avec une crainte
un poux et ton prendre notre voiture ce
matin la réponse était finalement oui il
est tombé que 2 cm de neige en moyenne
sur le territoire des Yvelines on peut
voir des images tournées aux quatre
coins du département c'était joli pour
les yeux il y avait des flocons sur le
toit des maisons mais pas de grosses
chutes de neige comme craint la veille
par Météo France de plus les services
des communautés d'agglomération et le
département avait bien salé les routes
principales sur l'ensemble du territoire
des Yvelines et ça roulait donc plutôt
bien aujourd'hui selon Bison Futé il y
avait moins de 150 km de bouchons à 8h30
mais attention quelques flocons
pourraient encore tomber dans la nuit on
est toujours en vigilance orange jusqu'à
ce jeudi et notamment à cause du verglas
après l'image du jour on passe à notre
chiffre du jour 250 pourquoi 250 ce sera
le nombre de policiers mobilisés ce soir
dans les Yvelines pendantccadrer la au
final de la coupe du monde entre la
France et le Maroc ils seront présents
principalement en zone police plus qu'en
zone gendarmerie ils auront pour
objectif d'encadrer l'aspect festif dans
une certaine limite comme nous
l'explique Julien de gère directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique
des Yvelines il était au micro de tv78
ce matin les zépites des commissariats
concernés
à Trappes donc ces commissaire
d'Élancourt à Mantes et aux Mureaux
seront engagés avec des niveaux
d'effectif supérieur à d'habitude les
moyens de la DDSP propre seront engagés
également donc les brigades cynophile la
compagnie d'intervention et les brigades
équestres et
la DDSP sera renforcée par une
demi-compagnie de CRS également et je
serai personnellement comme je l'ai fait
tous les soirs sur le terrain ce soir
avec mes troupes aux Mureaux
il y a eu 10 interpellations au total
samedi dernier dans les Yvelines suite à
la victoire de la France et du Maroc la
préfecture des Yvelines est revenue sur
le bilan de la lutte contre l'in
délinquance était ce matin Jean-Jacques
Bro le préfet des Yvelines a fait le
bilan aujourd'hui quelques chiffres dans
la zone gendarmerie la délinquance
générale est à la baisse de 3,95 % la
délinquance de proximité baisse elle
aussi de 4,5% par contre il y a une
hausse de 2% sur la teinte à l'intégrité
physique notamment à cause des violences
intrafamilales à notre chiffre il y a
une hausse de 40% des vols d'automobiles
dans la zone de gendarmerie du côté de
la police nationale 122 trafiquants de
drogue ont été interpellés depuis
septembre pour les rodé aux automobiles
il y a eu 38 procédures depuis septembre
notent également 4 à 16 garde à vue par
jour pour les violences conjugales enfin
pour les vols avec violence il y a une
diminution de 15% depuis le mois de
septembre il baisse de 6% des cam on
écoute le préfet des Yvelines nous avons
la ferme intention de continuer sur ces
priorités pour voir au bout de un
semestre ou même plus
en espérant que cette continueront les
chiffres continueront à être bien
orientés et dans la perspective que j'ai
aussi esquissé tout à l'heure d'une
préparation d'une anticipation des Jeux
Olympiques et voilà tout ça suppose
beaucoup de détermination de la part des
chefs de service qui sont à mes côtés on
va maintenant prendre la direction de
Maisons-Laffitte vous avez une bonne
nouvelle nickel la nouvelle n'est pas
encore officielle mais c'est en très
bonne voie l'hippodrome de la ville de
Maisons-Laffitte pourrait rouvrir
l'année prochaine en 2023 la société
organisatrice de course France Gallois a
fait un pas en ce sens ce lundi 12
décembre elle a prouvé les modalités
d'achat de l'hippodrome par
l'établissement public foncier
d'Ile-de-France une étape décisive selon
le maire de la commune Jacques Millard
la structure racheter pour le compte de
la ville depuis 2019 aucune course n'a
été organisée dans la commune ce qui
commence à faire très long pour les
passionnés de course de chevaux et vous
souhaitiez terminer par une dernière
information Michael le gouvernement
vient de dévoiler à l'information les
Yvelines font partie de la liste des 19
départements pour le dispositif RSA sous
conditions l'expérimentation préfigure
la future organisation France travail à
la pour but de faciliter l'insertion
professionnelle les allocateurs
devraient travailler entre 15 à 20h par
semaine pour bénéficier du Revenu de
Solidarité Active il sera mise en place
dans les Yvelines en 2023
l'expérimentation devrait concerner dans
un premier temps 30000 personnes
réparties sur ces 19 départements merci
beaucoup Mickaël midoro et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous avez vu
une information qui vous a marqué auprès
de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous le
communiquer en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news
on le disait en début d'émission ce
matin était présenté le campus des
métiers et des qualifications baptisés
industrie circulaire de la mobilité et
les situer sur le site de Renault flat à
Flins-sur-Seine Nicolas dandry vous y
étiez ce matin oui alors du coup je vous
le disais l'usine de Flins est en pleine
mutation ce site industrial historique
et bien se transforme le lancement du
campus des métiers et des qualifications
industries circulaires de la mobilité
s'inscrit dans cette transformation et
plusieurs personnalités
institutionnelles étaient présentes et
notamment Roland Lescure le ministre
délégué chargé de l'Industrie c'est une
révolution industrielle qui va nous
permettre à la fois de décarboner
l'industrie traditionnelle la voiture
mais on développant l'industrie de la
décarbonation et en accompagnement les
salariés de l'industrie d'hier
aujourd'hui vers l'industrie
d'aujourd'hui et de demain d'abord on
accompagne évidemment les employés
d'aujourd'hui vers le Renault de demain
mais ce qui m'intéresse surtout et on en
a rencontré ici un certain nombre qu'ils
font c'est que ce sont les employés
actuels qui eux-mêmes deviennent des
formateurs parce qu'ils connaissent le
groupe parce qu'ils travaillent certains
choisit d'autres afflins depuis
longtemps et que Renaud a été capable
volontaire pour les accompagner pour que
même deviennent on parle beaucoup
d'emplois des seniors ces temps-ci des
gens qui vont accompagner les jeunes
vers l'automobile de demain alors
Nicolas quels sont les différents
acteurs de ce nouveau campus alors vous
l'avez compris un acteur principal de ce
projet c'est Renaud group le
constructeur automobile veut bâtir le
premier site européen dédié à l'économie
circulaire de l'automobile à
Flins-sur-Seine une activité de
rénovation de pièces automobiles que
vous voyez déjà qui est déjà en
application sur le site il y a un
bâtiment aussi dédié aux
reconditionnement de véhicules inaugurés
en novembre 2021 il y a un an puis une
activité aussi autour des solutions de
mobilité hydrogène avec la filiale ivvia
et maintenant le campus et bien on
écoute à ce propos Jean Dominique Sennar
le président du conseil d'administration
de Renault cela va se transformer et
rester au cœur du automobile et vous
l'avez vu ce matin à travers les
installations sur l'hydrogène qui vont
ne cesser de grandir sur les 10 ans qui
viennent sur les installations sur
justement la reconfiguration des
véhicules tous ces aspects-là il y en a
bien d'autres vont occuper les nouveaux
locaux de fin et je pense que dans
quelques temps fleuve va être une
fourmilière les compétences l'économie
circulaire vous êtes ici dans ce campus
qui va permettre de traiter ce sujet je
pense que Renaud est très en pointe dans
cette affaire là mais Renaud n'est pas
seul Renaud vous l'avez vu est
accompagné à la fois par l'État par la
région par le rectorat par l'université
franchement ce matin c'était un exemple
fabuleux de ce que j'appelle la
collaboration publique privée une
collaboration publique privée avec
l'ensemble des partenaires qu'on vient
d'entendre et parmi ses partenaires il y
a l'université Versailles Saint-Quentin
et on écoute justement son président il
y a déjà des unités d'enseignement qui
seront appliquées ici et par et
construire réfléchi avec des
professionnels et des universitaires de
l'Université de Versailles 50 000 et de
Paris Saclay mais c'est également la
mise à disposition de l'ensemble de nos
forces tant de formations que de
recherche c'est-à-dire de pouvoir
réfléchir aux solutions de demain à
travers nos laboratoires en particulier
qui irriguent le Mantois qui aura savoir
faire ici mais également l'ensemble du
territoire des Yvelines alors Sylvie et
Artigues on vient d'entendre on l'a
compris c'est vraiment un campus dédié à
l'économie circulaire comment ça se
traduit de manière opérationnelle sur le
terrain
alors il a deux volets ce campus il est
né sur et vous l'avez très bien indiqué
sur le site de Renaud flying qui est en
transformation réelle depuis 2020 ou la
décision de la direction générale a été
de stopper la production des véhicules
dans l'usine
de manière concomitante la Direction
Générale a souhaité ne pas fermer le
site et le transformer en économie
circulaire et de ce fait cas de prendre
l'engagement de créer autant d'emplois
dans ces nouvelles activités qu'il que
le site contenait en termes d'effectif
autrement dit pour faire court 2000
emplois à horizon 2025 et un engagement
de 3000 horizon 2030
cet engagement de
réemployer de rediriger de transférer
les personnels de l'usine dans cette
nouvelle activité était le premier
engagement et forcément nécessitait un
plan massif de formation c'est de là
qu'est né le campus donc un premier
engagement qui est de former l'ensemble
des collaborateurs du site
sur la base de cet engagement nous avons
assez vite compris que on était pionnier
mais que probablement dans le tissu
économique global de l'automobile
d'autres seraient concernés voire
intéressés par des formations qui
intégreraient l'économie circulaire au
milieu de l'automobile et en fait de là
est né le campus avec un objectif
aujourd'hui de
créer enfin de former 8000 personnes
d'ici 2027 globalement donc pas
seulement Renault finalement en fait
c'était c'est parti en fait de la
transformation du site vous le disiez en
fait finalement les nouveaux les
salariés qui étaient déjà sur le site de
Flins-sur-Seine il fallait les former
aux nouvelles activités quels sont ces
nouvelles activités justement
concrètement c'est les former à quelle
activité alors tout à fait concrètement
Factory veo qui est le
l'activité dont on a le plus parlé donc
c'est peut-être celle que je vais citer
c'est une du reconditionnement de
véhicules d'occasion
nous a amenés à former de manière
différente les carrossiers les peintres
et les mécaniciens que nous avions dans
l'usine à faire non plus de la
carrosserie et de la peinture sur de
véhicules neufs mais sur des véhicules
d'occasion ça ne garde rien mais en fait
ça suppose un dispositif de formation au
moins d'adaptation à des compétences
qu'ils avaient de base bien évidemment
un carrossier à qui des compétences en
carrosserie néanmoins monter un véhicule
neuf et avoir des compétences en
carrosserie pour monter un véhicule neuf
c'est pas du tout la même chose que
avoir à réparer à rénover un véhicule
même récent mais qui est d'occasion
alors là vous parlez de métier
traditionnel de mécanique finalement il
y a aussi les métiers d'avenir ceux qui
n'existent pas encore absolument celui
que je peux vous citer qui fait partie
des métiers que l'on va préparer
prochainement il y a une heure au moins
deux il y en a qui sont liés à l'énergie
parce que quand on parle de
décarbonation on est obligé de parler
d'énergie et de solutions de stockage ce
sont des nouveaux métiers pour des
constructeurs automobiles pour nous
c'était des métiers que l'on qui était à
la périphérie dont on s'occupait
nécessairement des compétences dont on
avait besoin mais qu'on allait chercher
à l'extérieur là maintenant on commence
à les intégrer parce qu'on a bien
compris que les solutions de stockage et
de gestion d'énergie elles sont
indispensables en fait à tout système de
mobilité voilà donc en batterie pour
intégrer l'économie circulaire je vais
vous parler seulement moins de non pas
de production de de produits neufs mais
de produits usagers sur la partie
batterie et hydrogène typiquement nous
allons
former nous avons déjà commencé à former
des opérateurs qui montent la pile à
combustible à hydrogène que l'on monte
sur des véhicules hybrides hydrogène
électrique nous avons aussi des
opérateurs que nous formons sur les
secondes vies de batterie voire
troisième vie aujourd'hui c'est à dire
démonter des batteries et apprendre à
les démanteler et à les réemployer quand
vous parlez de batterie c'est des
batteries de véhicules électriques
absolument aujourd'hui vous êtes en
capacité parce que là c'est en train de
se démocratiser le véhicule électrique
mais vous êtes d'ores et déjà en
capacité pour les véhicules électriques
entre guillemets en fin de vie de
réutiliser la batterie qui était dans ce
véhicule concerné absolument l'activité
est déjà en place sur le site industriel
de Flins et elle est capacité elle peut
monter en capacité encore je vais vous
dire le problème que l'on a en fait il
est plutôt inverse c'est à dire il y a
pas suffisamment de batterie sur le
marché par rapport à la capacité que
nous avons à les recycler alors
justement vous tendez la perche
peut-être à la dernière question
justement il y a pas assez de
collaborateurs au sein du site de flan
pour justement aller sur ses activités
là je suppose que le dernier public que
vous adressez finalement c'est les
jeunes ceux qui vont un qui intègre
peut-être des lycéens des lycées
professionnels ceux qui vont peut-être
aller en étude supérieure et c'est un
public aussi que le campus adressant
c'est ça alors parfaitement et merci de
le souligner parce que
ce qu'on puisse étant situé sur le site
de Renault Flins évidemment on aurait
tendance à le à l'identifier à Renault
c'est pas tout à fait le cas c'est vrai
c'est son berceau et que c'est de là
qu'il est né et c'est important parce
que c'est pour nous un laboratoire de
ces nouveaux métiers précisément ce site
en transformation néanmoins nous avons
souhaité l'ouvrir et aujourd'hui il est
ouvert en effet à tous les
établissements du secondaire et du
supérieur des territoires on travaille
en réseau bien évidemment on peut pas
accueillir tous les établissements sur
le site nous essayons de travailler en
réseau et l'idée est progressivement de
ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon
académique de coloré des formations
existantes notamment dans l'automobile
en maintenance en automobile on est on
est en lien notamment avec
Mantes-la-Jolie des exemples en tête
de colorer progressivement des
formations jusqu'à pouvoir mettre en
place des diplômes c'est un peu long les
diplômes donc on va ça va nécessiter un
peu plus de temps donc là il y a d'ores
et déjà des élèves des étudiants lycéens
qui viennent sur le site de
Flins-sur-Seine parce que pour le moment
on essaie de d'adresser le le plus grand
nombre et donc sur des cours de périodes
il faut qu'on monte en compétence aussi
et en ressources progressivement mais
oui absolument merci beaucoup Sylvie
article du jeunesse d'avoir accepté
notre invitation je le rappelle vous
êtes la directrice de ce nouveau campus
industrie circulaire de la mobilité
située à Flins-sur-Seine on en parlait
en début de cette émission scène et
Yvelines numérique a reçu une
distinction pour le déploiement de la
fibre sur le territoire pour en parler
avec nous Robert Vallières vous êtes le
directeur général d'Yves linfibre alors
Robert Wallers c'est quoi exactement
evelynefibre est-ce que vous pouvez nous
le présenter alors Yvelines fibre c'est
une filiale du Groupe TDF donc Yvelines
fibre a été créé lorsque TDF a remporté
en fait à signer la convention avec le
département snivier numérique pour
déployer la fibre optique sur 150
communes du rural du sur les Yvelines
TDF c'est une grosse maison c'est 700
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
elle a 3 piliers globalement c'est la
diffusion de la TNT et de la radio FM
principalement ensuite c'est la
TDF mais à position également des
pylônes pour les opérateurs quels qu'ils
soient que les quatre opérateurs que
l'on connaît au niveau national et
ensuite le dernier métier qui est le
plus récent mais qui est aujourd'hui qui
se développe énormément chez TDF c'est
le développement de la fibre optique sur
les territoires sur le territoire
national
dans le réseau
objectif 100%. alors l'objectif de toute
façon d'un point de vue
au niveau d'un point de vue
réglementaire d'un point de vue
politique et pour Yvelines l'objectif
c'est que tout le monde puisse accéder à
la fibre optique puisqu'on sait en plus
que dans quelques années alors est-ce
que ça sera 2025 2030 le cuivre va
disparaître donc il est indispensable de
toute façon que tous les foyers puissent
accéder à la fibre optique quels sont
les enjeux je suppose que ce sont plutôt
les zones rurales non aujourd'hui il y a
eu un énorme travail qui a été réalisé
pour aller chercher des foyers les plus
isolés typiquement on a fait 400 km de
travaux de génie civil notamment pour
aller chercher des des fermes isolées
etc donc ça ce travail là il est il est
fait à
99%, on a encore des petites choses et
qu'on partage avec les communes le plus
compliqué c'est plutôt les les petits
immeubles collectifs parce que pour
fibrer un immeuble on est obligé
d'installer la fibre optique dans les
privative et on rentre pas comme ça dans
un dans un immeuble donc il faut signer
une convention alors si une convention
avec un immeuble qui fait 15 20
logements il y a un syndic donc c'est
relativement simple par contre quand ce
sont des immeubles qui ont 4 ou 5
logements ben c'est de temps en temps 4
ou 5 locataires on sait pas où est le
propriétaire il peut être en France il
peut être à Paris il peut être etc et
donc c'est ce qui reste principalement
c'est en fait les petits collectifs vous
avez rencontré d'autres obstacles
d'autres freins lors du déploiement de
la fibre alors des freins on en a plein
sinon ça serait pas drôle alors le
premier vous parliez de la météo tout à
l'heure où il fait très froid enfin il
fait que -2 on a déployé en quatre ans
on a connu toutes les conditions
météorologiques possibles et imaginables
des très fortes chaleurs en été très
vaste température également il y a eu
des inondations aussi il y a un an ou
deux donc les conditions météorologiques
qui sont extrêmement compliquées ensuite
les infrastructures qu'il faut
renouveler c'est à dire que 400 km de
travaux de génie civil c'est pas ça
c'est pas vous voyez c'est Paris Lyon
quoi Paris Lyon c'est 470 km mais on a
fait 400 km à part que c'est pas un
grand chantier c'est des petits
chantiers de 1 km de 500 mètres de 700 m
on a changé plus de 1000 poteaux sur sur
le territoire des Yvelines parce que ils
étaient ils avaient besoin d'être changé
donc c'est plein de petites choses qui
font que à l'arrivée on arrive à faire
un déploiement on a tiré juste un
dernier chiffre on a tiré 6500 km de
câbles sur le territoire
vous avez des compétences nécessaires
peut-être qu'il va falloir faire un
campus un campus de la fibre optique
parce que je suppose que c'est aussi des
métiers qui sont en tension comme ou des
métiers à créer peut-être aussi alors il
y a eu ces semer ces métiers là étaient
en très très forte tension puisque il y
a eu un plan national avec le président
Macron pour avoir la forme la France qui
soit fibrée d'ici 2025
ce plan aujourd'hui il est en il est on
va dire il a atteint son pic et
maintenant on est en train d'atterrir
même s'il reste encore beaucoup de
choses à faire sur le territoire
national donc c'était des métiers en
très forte tension il y a il y a il y a
très peu de temps aujourd'hui maintenant
le métier il rentre beaucoup sur les
aspects maintenant de réseau et puis sur
les raccordeurs puisque il y a
énormément de raccordement on est
aujourd'hui le territoire 50% des foyers
que globalement qui sont éligibles à la
fibre optique ont pris un abonnement à
la fibre il reste ça veut dire qu'il
reste encore énormément de raccordeurs à
faire donc il y a eu un énorme travail
de formation effectivement ces dernières
années là on rentre plutôt dans une
phase de rentabilité il y a quand même
certains certains yvelinesois qui
déplorent des problèmes liés à la fibre
ils sont sans cesse déconnectées comment
est-ce qu'on peut améliorer ces
conditions d'accès à la fibre alors il y
a d'abord un travail qui est réalisé au
niveau national avec l'Autorité de
régulation des communications et des
postes la recette pour voir comment on
peut améliorer les process à travers des
outils tels que l'intelligence
artificielle comment on peut travailler
entre les avec les opérateurs puisque en
fait les raccordements sont réalisés par
les opérateurs c'est à dire que Yveline
fibre met à disposition son réseau aux
opérateurs qui vont ensuite réaliser les
raccordements donc il y a tout un
travail qui est réalisé entre les
opérateurs ce qu'on appelle les
opérateurs d'infrastructures Yvelines
fibre en étain et les opérateurs qui a
réalisé les raccordements mais au-delà
de ça d'un point de vue statistique
alors on est on est toujours sur
uniquement au niveau de statistique mais
globalement le réseau Yvelines fibre et
les réseaux TDF ont un niveau de qualité
qui est supérieur à la moyenne et en
tout cas c'est ce qui apparaît dans sur
le site de l'ARCEP
aura lieu la remise
des dispositifs l'entrepreneuriat pour
tous Alexandra Rosetti la
vice-présidente déléguée au
développement économique et à
l'attractivité du territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines a accepté de
répondre à nos questions
[Musique]
alors c'est pour récompenser ceux qui
ont suivi la formation de
l'entrepreneuriat pour tous
jusqu'au bout
l'entrepreneuriat pour tous c'est un
nouveau dispositif qui a été mis en
place l'année dernière par ski cube à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
accompagner les créateurs d'entreprises
enfin ceux qui veulent créer leur
entreprise
sur cette promotion donc c'est la
deuxième promotion puisque on a commencé
l'an dernier on a eu 60 candidatures on
en a retenu 11 dont 8 femmes
voilà donc c'est c'est 11 candidatures
c'est 11 personnes que nous avons suivi
pendant 3 mois que nous allions nous
allons récompenser demain
si on veut regarder le bilan de l'année
dernière sur les 14 stagiaires que nous
avions l'an dernier nous en avons huit
qui ont créé leur entreprise donc ça
veut dire que le dispositif qu'on met en
place
rencontre son public
il correspond à un besoin et donc nous
en sommes vraiment très très satisfait
[Musique]
ça apporte beaucoup à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines d'abord
évidemment parce que
ça permet de créer de l'emploi
c'est-à-dire ça permet à des personnes
qui des fois ce sont des personnes qui
sont éloignées de l'emploi ou qui sont
demandeurs d'emploi qui qui se disent je
vais créer mon entreprise et lorsqu'ils
sont bien accompagnés merci leur
entreprise se développe ça crée aussi de
l'emploi donc c'est vraiment un
dispositif
gagnant-gagnant nous ça nous permet de
conserver une dynamique d'encourager
aussi des projets par exemple liés à
l'innovation
[Musique]
on va parler de sport durable à présent
certains professionnels se demandent
comment réduire leurs impacts sur
l'environnement notamment au niveau de
leur équipement sportif par exemple des
chaussures de foot peuvent être
remplacées tous les six mois en fonction
du niveau du joueur et avec nous pour en
parler David rang des bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller en formation pour l'école win
sport school alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter un petit peu cette
école c'est une école du management du
sport qui est donc forme des étudiants
une formation type école de commerce
mais spécifiquement au domaine du sport
et aux métiers qui tourne autour du
sport et du sport business on a
identifié
assez récemment d'ailleurs en rapport
avec la Coupe du Monde aussi
qui avait un déficit et une vraie
opportunité dans les nouveaux métiers
dans la récupération d'équipements
sportifs par exemple
donc on a décidé de faire travailler
étudiants dans le cadre dans le cadre
d'un projet national qui s'appelle win
sengage puisque windsportschool c'est 22
campus à travers la France et donc on a
créé un gros challenge
qu'on puisse par campus
alors le challenge c'est tout d'abord
une phase de qualification sur chaque
campus avec des équipes d'étudiants qui
vont travailler sur des projets des
projets qui peuvent nourrir l'économie
circulaire permettre de limiter l'impact
du
du sport sur la consommation
concrètement ils ont travaillé sur quel
projet il y avait des projets dans le
eSport puisque c'est un domaine qui se
développait énormément donc par exemple
la récupération de matériel informatique
dans le cadre d'événements eSport les
chaussures comme vous avez cité tout à
l'heure chaque enfant qui fait du
football par exemple va consommer
beaucoup de paires de chaussures au fil
des années grandit vite les pieds
grandissent donc les chaussures sont
parfois pas usées donc autant les
récupérer l'objectif c'est ça par
exemple on a aussi un groupe qui s'est
trouvé deux partenaires donc un club de
football du 92 et puis une entreprise
qui fabrique des ballons à partir de
plastique recyclé à trouver en mer ou au
bord des routes voilà donc il y a plein
de projets comme ça qui sont émergents
il y a un projet qui a gagné aujourd'hui
on a élu le meilleur projet du campus de
50 ans en Yvelines aujourd'hui qui va
s'affront qui va affronter les autres
projets vainqueurs et donc le projet
vainqueur de 50 ans en Yvelines c'est
lequel alors là du coup c'est le projet
qui a été élu c'est celui qui va être en
partenariat avec l'entreprise Vista et
le GPS au 92 le club de football féminin
d'ici les Moulineaux et qui va permettre
de récupérer du plastique pour aider
Vista à fabriquer des ballons et donc
réduire l'impact des sportifs finalement
sur notre environnement donc si je
comprends bien le sport durable c'est du
reconditionnement en fait voilà
c'est surtout ce que les projets qu'on
choisit nos étudiants cette année chacun
a sa créativité et aujourd'hui c'est les
projets qui sont sortis cette semaine
donc vous l'avez dit il y a 22 campus en
France le sport durable c'est l'avenir
Satan à se développer selon vous ça fait
partie des métiers qui vont être
émergents on l'a vu avec la Coupe du
Monde de Qatar qui fait très polémique
ils ont réussi à fabriquer des stabs des
stades démontables pour certains qui
vont être recyclés réutilisés dans
d'autres pays c'est nouveau c'est
inattendu il y a encore ou comme ça
beaucoup d'opportunités dans le sport
beaucoup d'opportunités à découvrir le
sport ça reste un loisir il faut réduire
votre empreinte carbone grâce au sport
on a la possibilité de le faire et donc
vous trouvez que les sportifs sont
sensibilisés à cette question
extrêmement sensibilisés ils prennent
déjà soin d'eux ils prennent soin des
autres ils sont sensibilisés à beaucoup
de questions de ce type là puisque c'est
les
critères de réussite pour les sportifs
donc les gens qui aiment le sport font
très attention oui que reste-t-il à
faire j'ai envie de dire dans ce secteur
dans ce domaine pour améliorer son
impact sur l'environnement
je les connais pas tous si j'avais
toutes les clés ce serait facile non
j'ai il y a énormément d'efforts à
fournir
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de on a vu dans
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar les Japonais
par exemple nous montrer l'exemple
ramasser leur déchets dans les tribunal
à la fin des matchs ça c'est quelque
chose qui est un détail mais on organise
des grandes courses le Tour de France en
est une par exemple qui génère beaucoup
de déchets c'est ça peut être la
polémique et je pense que là dessus il y
a un vrai un vrai travail à fournir et
les jeunes sont très très sensibles à ça
on a régulièrement des jeunes qui nous
posent la question comment ils peuvent
faire comment ils peuvent s'investir et
on les voit avec beaucoup de projets ça
c'est donc au sein de votre école vous
proposez plusieurs formations est-ce que
vous pouvez nous les présenter voilà on
a un cursus qui s'étend sur cinq années
d'abord un Bachelor qui est un bac + 3
management du sport très orienté
commerce communication marketing
événementielle on s'est avant tout un
cursus d'école de commerce votre orienté
management du sport et métiers du sport
sport business
pareil on a un MBA un bac + 4,5 qui
permet à nos étudiants aussi de pouvoir
continuer leur cursus jusqu'à un niveau
bac + 5 un niveau Master et ce qui donne
beaucoup de connaissances et de
compétences spécifiques dans le monde du
sport il y en a beaucoup qui s'orientent
vers l'événementiel
la relation de partenariat
management dans le sport et on y rentre
comment dans cette dans cette école il y
a trois critères pour intégrer nos
formations le premier c'est un critère
purement scolaire un dossier de
candidature avec quel étudiant on va
être quelle étudiant on était le
deuxième c'est le projet sportif un
entretien individuel
qui est avec un conseiller en formation
moi ou un autre et ensuite il y a un
test à effectuer un test en ligne donc
chaque candidature est étudiée de façon
individualisée et chaque étudiant va
avoir une personne référente tout au
long de son cursus de chez nous merci
beaucoup David Ringuet d'être venu en
plateau avec nous je le rappelle vous
êtes conseiller formation pour l'école
winesport school cette année
saint-germain-lait fête le 45e
anniversaire de son jumelage avec achat
fenburg en Allemagne à cette occasion
des jeunes du lycée Jeanne d'Albret de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et des lycéens de
la ville allemande ont visité récemment
le Parlement européen de Strasbourg ils
ont pu notamment échanger avec des euros
députés une action avec le soutien du
fond citoyen franco-allemand le
reportage de Jessie Willens de nos
confrères radiocensation nous sommes
devant le Parlement européen il est
composé de 7505 euros députés et il a
pour fonction de représenter les
citoyens de l'Union européenne à travers
le comité de jumelage d'achat funbourg
et Saint-Germain-en-Laye des lycéens des
deux pays sont venus rencontrer et
débattre avec des euros députés
avant tout un continent c'est-à-dire un
continent sur lequel se trouve tous les
pays membres et d'autre part cela
signifie aussi pour moi une organisation
qui veille à ce que la paix soit
entretenu et respectée sur le continent
et que les citoyens comprennent cela et
que l'on prête attention aux intérêts de
chaque pays
voir plus clair sur la fonction d'un
neurodéputé mais pourquoi la thématique
de l'environnement semble être une
priorité pour la jeunesse
l'environnement qui renferme d'ailleurs
de propose problématique on fait pas
quelque chose pour
on peut pas arrêter le réchauffement
climatique mais pour aider à ce que le
réchauffement climatique baisse un peu
bah c'est bah c'est important parce que
c'est un peu on travaille pour notre
survie je pense qu'on réagit trop tard
parce qu'on s'en est pas rendu compte
enfin si on s'en rendait compte mais on
se dit on se disait bah on va faire ça
après on va se dire on attendait un
certain point de où la situation
devenait ingérable et on peut pas faire
de retour en arrière mais malgré le fait
que bah là bah c'est c'est pas terrible
il faut continuer à faire des efforts et
pas arrêter et se dire bah que c'est
trop tard les lycéens ont rencontré
Marie-Pierre Védrenne euro député
françaises et Luc carston euro député
allemand attiré la jeunesse c'était
d'ailleurs l'un des objectifs de l'Union
européenne pour l'année 2022 à travers
le dispositif européenne de la jeunesse
l'idée est simple sensibiliser et
intéresser les jeunes aux problématiques
européennes je pense qu'il est
extrêmement important pour l'Union
européenne d'être connecté aux jeunes
générations parce que les décisions que
nous prenons maintenant ont un impact
bien sûr dans le présent mais surtout
elle construisent le futur donc elle
construisent des politiques qui vont
impacter les jeunes générations c'est
pour ça que c'est essentiel de
travailler tout de suite avec leur
expliquer aussi la réalité de notre
action parce que moi il y a pas un jour
où je vais dans une intervention
scolaire où les jeunes me demandent mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites pour le climat
on voit qu'on a aussi un enjeu de
visibilité de notre action donc c'est
pour ça que accueillir des groupes
intervenir dans le cadre scolaire
appuyer des événements pour que les gens
se croisent pour que les gens échangent
pour que les gens dialoguent pour
confronter les idées c'est absolument
essentiel toute l'année c'est donc au
Parlement européen situé à Strasbourg
que les euros députés se rassemblent ils
y vote et ils débattent sur les
différentes problématiques de l'Europe
plus d'informations sur le site
europa.eu
comme chaque mercredi c'est l'heure
maintenant de passer à notre page cinéma
et on commence pas par cette sortie dans
les salles de cinéma qui est tant
attendu par les Français avatar de la
voix de l'eau très en après le premier
volet de la saga James Cameron remplit
avec un deuxième volet qui s'annonce
spectaculaire Luc Bocan le directeur du
ciné 7 telencourt nous en parle regardez
aujourd'hui mercredi 14 décembre 2022
nous sortons dans nos belles salles du
ciné 7 à Élancourt
le volet numéro 2 du 13 attendu avatar
12 ans 11 ans je sais plus exactement
après le premier épisode donc avatar la
voix de l'eau réalisée par le fameux
James Cameron qu'on entend partout dans
les médias aujourd'hui
trois heures 12 de films évidemment un
film qui a été réalisé en vrai 3D ça
c'est important de le dire parce que on
a été obligé de cavaler un petit peu
pour remettre à niveau tout notre
équipement 3D que nous n'avions pas
utilisé depuis des lustres période de
covid en plus en plus voilà donc tout ça
fonctionne très bien je rassure les
spectateurs et donc Cameron moi je lui
rends hommage parce que c'était quand
même un grand monsieur du cinéma qui
travaille énormément qui adore les
nouvelles technologies qui adorent l'eau
vous le savez vous du très beau abis
qu'il a réalisé il y a très longtemps et
donc il insiste beaucoup et ça c'est
très appréciable pour nous exploitants
pour que son film sorte exclusivement en
sortie mondiale dans les cinémas voilà
j'insiste là-dessus et pas sur les
plateformes dans toutes les interviews
qu'il fait il redit l'importance de la
salle de cinéma de ce lieu magique où
nous partageons ensemble des émotions le
film n'est pas est-il très réussi je ne
l'ai pas encore vu mais il paraît qu'on
ne voit pas passer les trois heures 12
de films donc nous le projetons aussi
les 7 pendant 4 semaines au moins en 3D
et en 2D en VF dans un premier temps
parce que c'est les ce sont les
l'intelligence du distributeur mais on
récupérera de la VO à partir de la
troisième semaine et nous vous attendons
donc très nombreux pour découvrir avec
nous ce très beau film très
spectaculaire avatar la voix de l'eau
poursuit cette page cinéma par le coup
de cœur d'un professionnel du 7e art
cette semaine c'est la réalisatrice Géna
souru qui vous propose son coup de cœur
regardez le film que je recommande et
l'événement de Audrey d'Ivan l'événement
raconte un rite de passage tout
particulier puisque c'est celui d'une
jeune femme qui se trouve confrontée au
choix d'avorter mais malheureusement pas
dans les conditions qu'on aimerait
puisqu'il s'agit d'un film d'époque et
que cette jeune femme est une étudiante
brillante dans le cœur de la France des
années 60
ça y est c'est fini vous allez vous
allez rater vos examens
oui non non ce que j'ai trouvé
formidable dans ce film c'est à quel
point il ne fait pas de cadeau au sujet
de l'avortement il est vraiment très cru
par rapport à la réalité et il monte une
certaine manière la réalité notamment à
travers des personnages et une
interprétation des acteurs qui est
absolument exceptionnel ce qui est très
intéressant aussi dans ce film c'est le
travail sur la lumière et le travail sur
les décors qui d'une certaine manière
font vraiment partie intégrante de ce
rythme initiatique un petit peu un petit
peu macabre et un petit peu un petit peu
qui fait malheureusement écho avec la
période actuelle et ce que j'admire
énormément finalement dans le travail
d'audredivan c'est à quel point elle a
pu traiter ce sujet extrêmement délicat
de manière à faire vivre une expérience
au public qui permet de questionner et
de faire vivre le sujet de l'avortement
puisque comme pour n'importe un sujet il
est important surtout d'en parler et de
continuer d'éduquer afin de protéger des
droits qui sont fondamentaux mais qu'il
faut toujours continuer à conserver et à
ne jamais considérer comme acquis
et bientôt la fin de cette émission mais
juste avant on retrouve notre
journaliste Grégory canalet vous êtes au
bar up to you à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
qui va diffuser dans quelques heures
dans moins d'une heure le match la
demi-finale France Maroc quelle est
l'ambiance sur place Grégory
et bien l'ambiance se monte vraiment
grandement sur place depuis qu'on s'est
eu tout à l'heure Mathilde vraiment là
les supporters sont arrivés on a vu
quelques visages peintures l'urée des
couleurs bleu blanc rouge ce soir
vraisemblablement il y aura beaucoup
plus de supporters d'équipes de France
que de supporters du Maroc des Lions de
l'Atlas ici dans ce bar up to you de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le coup d'envoi
est à 20h mais ça y est les tables sont
remplies justement alors j'ai deux
supporters de l'équipe de France qui
sont avec moi Jeanne et Thibault bonsoir
Jeanne on va commencer avec vous bah
pourquoi vous êtes venu tout simplement
ici ce soir pour supporter les Bleus
avec avec vos amis avec mes collègues
bah parce que c'est important c'est la
Coupe du Monde et puis il faut être
présent pour les français pour être sûr
d'arriver au bout voilà
Thibault même question pourquoi choisir
de venir dans un bar plutôt de regarder
la rencontre chez vous ce soir on va
faire la fête avec les copains ensemble
tout le pays est en ébullition on veut
participer à ça et ici c'est un super
endroit pour ça qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la rencontre de ce soir la
France fait figure de favori dans ce
match mais à la façade une équipe
marocaine qui a quand même éliminé
l'Espagne le Portugal dans les derniers
tours est-ce que vous vous croyez aux
champs de bleu que qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce match bah on est en
croissance des Bleus on est supporters
on a envie de faire la fête maintenant
c'est une demi-finale de Coupe du monde
et à ce niveau-là il peut tous se passer
donc le suspense sera entier puis on va
essayer de passer un bon moment voilà
vous voyez un des supporters derrière
qui
montre quelques bières bien sûr à
consommer avec modération jeune
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de du match ce
soir est-ce que vous pensez que les les
Bleus ont toute leur chance c'est quand
même favori hein oui je pense qu'ils ont
leur chance maintenant c'est quand même
un match important pour au Maroc parce
qu'ils sont jamais arrivés à tel niveau
donc c'est trop cool pour eux mais bon
on est quand même pour la France quoi tu
pronostic
[Rires]
[Musique]
savoir aussi beaucoup de l'attaquant en
pointe Olivier Giroud qui est devenu au
cours de cette compétition le meilleur
buteur de l'histoire des Bleus est-ce
qu'on peut avoir un petit aller les
Bleus pour les Bleus ce soir
allez les bleus
vous voyez c'est timide mais les
supporters sont quand même là et on le
rappelle le coup d'envoi de cette
demi-finale France Maroc de la Coupe du
Monde c'est à 20h et vous Grégory est-ce
que vous avez un pronostic
moi Mathis je le disais au cours des
émissions j'ai tendance à porter malheur
à l'équipe que je pronostique l'équipe
que je donne vainqueur donc ce soir je
veux pas faire jaloux même si au fond
peut-être je disais la France fait
figure de favorites si on se base
vraiment sur les forces en présence pas
de pronostic ce soir mais on espère
quand même un beau match une très belle
demi-finale entre la France et le Maroc
et bien merci beaucoup Grégory canalet
on souhaite bonne chance à notre équipe
de France et avant de se quitter je vous
propose de regarder la météo de demain
demain matin le ciel sera voilé sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera encore très froid
compter moins 4 degrés à Rambouillet -3
à Houdan et Versailles et moins de
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie mais les
ressentis seront en moyenne de moins 8
degrés alors couvrez-vous bien dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se dégager
avec quelques éclaircies au niveau des
températures il fera 1 degré à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan et
0 à Rambouillet et on se quitte avec
cette information tournée avant les
dernières chutes de neige dans les
Yvelines en début de semaine une
opération de restauration de vergers a
été menée au domaine de
Dampierre-en-Yvelines ce sont les
membres de l'association des Croqueurs
de Pommes d'Île-de-France qui ont assuré
le chantier une dégradation des arbres
fruitiers avait été constaté depuis
quelques mois plusieurs actions de
taillage de reprise et d'élagage des
arbres ont été ainsi mis en place en
partenariat avec le domaine le tout sous
la direction de François moulin ancien
jardinier en chef du Potager du Roi à
Versailles les propos recueillis par
Julien Leroy s'agissait de redonner aux
arbres la forme d'origine on peut le
constater sur le mur là il y avait donc
des espaliers des arbres en cordon et
puis des arbres de plein vent des
pommiers en plein vent donc en formule
libre qu'on a dû aussi élaguer donc on a
passé deux journées à faire ce travail
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité on se retrouve
demain soir pour une édition spéciale
Noël je vous souhaite une belle soirée
sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]